let's take some audience questions Kevin
wrote in Kevin has a really good
question
Kevin says should I feel guilty about
being in the oil and gas industry after
17 years
no college diploma kids mortgage etc
only recently understanding the science
of climate change I do feel guilty by
the way it bothers me a lot this is a
good question I mean I think the fact
that Kevin is even asking these
questions means he's already way more
sort of self actualized than endless
people that are working in oil and gas I
think that it's fine to understand the
way in which your industry is damaging
our planet
now if Kevin didn't work in this
industry they would just find someone
else to replace Kevin now I I don't say
that because I think that it's a good
argument to defend the employment
necessarily but the truth is the changes
that are going to need to happen to
really change the fossil fuel paradigm
it's going to be more than just people
quitting and you know what even if
everybody quit working in these fields
sooner or later a lot of the tasks would
be automated anyway so I think it's
perfectly the fact that Kevin is asking
these questions the fact that Kevin
feels guilty about working in oil and
gas it means that he is an empathetic
person he is someone who understands how
human activities are damaging our planet
but we need structural change to really
get us out of this fossil fuel paradigm
and Kevin is you know in a position
where he's working the best job he could
get given the education that he has it's
hard to fault someone for that
although again he does recognize that
the industry as a whole is very damaging
to the planet yeah it's important to
point out too that we still rely on oil
and gas as it is today a fair point you
know we have to move on to renewable
sources of energy but if it all just
disappeared tomorrow a lot of us would
be screwed how would we get to work
don't we heat our homes that's another
point which is let's assume Kevin
quitting did impact the industry in some
significant way we're not actually
equipped today
to get off of fossil fuels through
almost completely our own fault
but that's just a reality and that's a
transition that's going to need to
happen so Kevin yes you should feel
guilty but that doesn't mean that you
need to quit and endanger your own
livelihood it's also the fault of our
elected officials that we have these
jobs rather than other jobs right and
the fact that this might be the place I
don't know where Kevin lives but it
might be the place where he is actually
able to earn a living that's not his
fault that's a structural reality and
who knows what other industries and jobs
are even available at the place that he
lives
exactly it's also thinking of the way of
you know my commitment to my family
versus my commitment to my community
into the environment and all that stuff
and people rank those things differently
it's different for everybody and you
know I I do I strongly believe that at
this point if you are not concerned
about climate change you either are
unaware of its reality or you are
someone that doesn't care about other
people could be future people whatever
right I mean at this point there's
really no way around that
just having this job doesn't mean that
you're a bad person I hope if Kevin was
writing in for validation that he's not
a bad person I'm able to say that but
still say you should probably feel
guilty to some degree because yeah it's
the industry is a major problem